[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola
durante mi infancia
los últimos años mis padres han estado
muy presentes más durante mi infancia
casi no mi madre a la que estaba más
presente siendo ama de casa ya cuidaba a
mis hermanos ya mi y mi papá por el
contrario siendo ingeniero civil pasaba
muchas largas temporadas fuera de casa a
veces es taaan tijuana el mérida y no
estaba no estaba en casa muy seguido
entonces no lo veía muy seguido no lo
escuchaba mucho más cuando yo entré a
secundar y sobre todo en prepa estaba
más presente
al estar más presente mi papá me
limitaba un poquito de no voy a estar
reuniones no salgas ya cuando mis amigos
iban al antro no vayas al antro y
también siempre me esforzaba un poquito
hacer cosas que o planes que él quería
obviamente esto causa un poquito de
fricciones
yo me pensaba si no estuviste muchos
años ahorita porque sí y por qué me
vienes a dar órdenes
después al paso de mi temporada en la
preparatoria mi papá me dejó grandes
enseñanzas que no escuchaba a veces por
joven no escuchaban te entra por un oído
te sale por otro y te bloqueas mi papá
me decía siempre se humilde con todos y
ante todos
mi mamá también me daba muchas gracias
enseñanzas como me hablaba de valores y
me hablaba del respeto a uno mismo
siempre me decía max aquí en china en
japón donde sea los valores son los
mismos
pareciera y es impactante como nuestros
papás nos dicen las cosas como si
supiera que ya como si supieran que nos
iba a pasar si tuvieran una bolita de
cristal y que nos vieran en un futuro y
dijeran le va a pasar a mi hijo le voy a
decir esto y pácatelas
pues así pasó
después todo empezó cuando me fui a
estudiar dos años a canadá
me llevé estas enseñanzas conmigo de mis
padres iba muy bien en la escuela empecé
a estudiar la administración
y termino mi segundo año conseguí una
beca para irme a estudiar a la
universidad de jong y en corea del sur
hice mi diplomado de verano todo iba muy
bien mi vida pintaba muy bien está
estudiando tenía buenas calificaciones
no tenía más que el objetivo de regresar
a canadá a graduarme
note el objetivo más quería regresar a
canadá de graduarme y seguir con mi
éxito profesional como profesionista
a mi regreso de corea en el tercer año
se me presentó una oportunidad ya están
otra vez en canadá yo voy a hacer mi
super
y cuando hago mi super se me acerque a
una persona y me dice oye te ofrezco
hacer una sesión de fotos claro que yo
me espanté dije esto no es normal porque
me están ofreciendo esto a mí
hice la sesión de fotos más no sabía lo
que iba a replicar al paso de los días
me hablan de una agencia boutique de la
ciudad de vancouver y me dicen te
queremos ofrecer un contrato y queremos
que hagas una sesión yo hice una sesión
como modelo de apoyo sin paga
pero dije que sigue y me quedo céntrica
y me entró ese gusto entonces pues lo
seguí haciendo durante ese mes ese
semestre dejando un poquito al lado los
estudios que pasó pues throne todas mis
materias ese tercer semestre ese tercer
año ya no podía entrar a la escuela el
siguiente semestre me habían dicho max
no puedes entrar en todo el año y tienes
que esperarte a repetir todo híjole
qué hago me llegará un chorro de nervios
tenía dudas me regreso a mexico como le
digo mis papás que voy a hacer
entonces como mi personaje favorito se
me ocurrió una maravillosa pero terrible
idea una maravillosa y terrible idea y
ahorita les voy a contar por qué
los convencí de irme a vancouver de
quedarme ahí tomar unas materias
mientras me entraba otra vez a la
escuela
ya estando en vancouver instalado sin
haber entrado a estudiar materias llego
a la agencia y les digo ya estoy aquí
quiero hacer unos castings y quiero
hacer esto de lleno al menos por el año
que tenía sin hacer nada
paso de estar haciendo proyectos
chiquitos de una agencia boutique de
canadá a estar firmando con una agencia
internacional
también de la misma ciudad teniendo
proyectos con mayor magnitud tenían
compañeros que ya están modelando en la
semana de la moda de nueva york habían
hecho campañas editoriales en asia y que
estaban haciendo comerciales en los
ángeles los proyectos sean de mayor
magnitud y cada vez será más demanda y
claro yo con mis limitantes fuera de ser
morenito de 178 a veces me bloqueaban me
decían solamente te vamos a dar cosas
comerciales catálogos y hasta ahí pero
yo quiere hacer más cosas yo quería
fijarme este objetivo de lleno y les
dije por favor mandarme a más castings
me voltean a ver cómo que estaba loco
178 en un mundo así es
no la vas a hacer y empezando también
porque entras un cuarto imagínense
ustedes cuando van un casting entras un
cuarto lleno de modelos entre mujeres y
hombres y todo se te quedan viendo así y
stevie que no se aparte chaparrito yo
entonces literal le ponía mi gorra mis
audífonos y así caminaba me sentaba
hasta que me tocaba mi turno de hacer el
casting y así me fui así yo veía como
los demás modelos venían hola cómo estás
qué onda se saludaban porque habían
trabajado juntos pero yo no yo era el
nuevo
de ahí fui un poquito a poquito haciendo
más cosas
hasta llegar a hacer más cosas estar de
sets pequeñitos de catálogo a estar
haciendo
a estar haciendo sesiones a estar
haciendo publicidad en sets donde había
luces donde había estilistas maquillaje
peinado el estay leer te venía
prácticamente eras el centro de atención
y obviamente tu ego se levanta osea
imagínense ustedes cuando le dicen oye
le gusta es una chava le gusta es un
chavo luego se levanta imaginen estar
ahí con la atención de todos obviamente
te sientes como decimos nosotros la que
miren box como un millón de dólares
el sentimiento es increíble
lamentablemente sales y nadie te conoce
yo llegaba en mi departamento y decía
ahora aquí no había luces no había
cámaras no había nadie ahora que hago no
tenía escuela y baldwin sí pero pues qué
más hago
ese sentimiento de ya que hago trabajo
en mí un sentimiento de soledad
de ansiedad y en ciertas formas a veces
un poquito de depresión
con los durante estos trabajos también
conocí otros modelos que venían de rusia
que venían de irlanda que venían de
pueblitos de canadá buscando un objetivo
y un sueño un sueño alejándose de lo que
eran sus valores lo que era su familia
lo que eran sus amigos de años y nos
veíamos teníamos entre 17 y 21 años
realmente éramos chamacos o sea teníamos
que jóvenes
y niños y la mujer ni sería porque ya
desde los 15 años entonces estábamos
envueltos en una vulnerabilidad muy alta
estando expuestos a excesos estando
expuesto a amistades que van y vienen
que te manipulan y te llevan a algo que
no está bien
esos sentimientos a mí me hicieron
agarrarme de lo que comenté ahorita y
salir de fiesta me quedé un estigma de
que el modelo tenía que ir a ser muy
ping-pong su trabajo y que después salir
de fiesta con sus amigos y al día
siguiente lo mismo entonces me creó un
hábito un hábito de que de salir de
fiesta y de acostumbrarme a ir a ir
teniendo ese estigma
después
perdón que viva
teniendo ese estigma allá
entonces me acostumbré a ir de fiesta en
fiesta y me causaban muchos desgastes y
me causaba también la mentalidad de que
flojera mañana me tengo que levantar
tengo un casi mejor lo hago al día
siguiente ya no quiero ir al gimnasio no
comidas bien te desvela vas te desgasta
vas está perdiendo peso un desgaste
constante y excesos constantes y salir
de fiesta y no dormir y no comer y
entonces me llevo a tener un colapso
colapso tan fuerte que me llevó a estar
postrada en una cama cinco días
fueron los cinco días más horribles de
mi vida
como alguien que tenía objetivos sueños
alguien activo y dinámico había quedado
postrado en una cama por cinco días y lo
peor es que los primeros tres días no
podría abrir los ojos
no podía ni levantar el celular me
tenían que cargar para poder yo entrar a
hacerme y no podía abrir mis ojos yo no
entendía lo que me había hecho yo a mí
mismo yo escuchaba en la clínica voces y
escuchaba a mis amigos hablar y no
entendía no podía moverme y no podía no
puede abrir mis ojos
sentía que las luces las cámaras y los
flashes de mi vida se me iban
el quinto día despierto me siento un
poquito mejor fue cuando dije la vida me
estaba en una segunda oportunidad una
segunda oportunidad de levantarme y con
la misma agarro un vuelo me vine a
méxico me vine a méxico a construir me
otra vez desde cero con mi familia con
amigos con lo que me gustaba recordando
quién era cuál eran mis objetivos y qué
me pasó
no tienes que haber estado en mi
situación hay muchas cosas muchos
ejemplos en la vida sufrimiento de
bullying represión por su orientación
sexual
qué cosas simples como si te equivocaste
de carrera realmente cosas que a veces
uno como humano como joven dice ya estoy
derrotado y no sé ni para dónde agarrar
me pero no
es para cuando demuestras que tu fuerza
de voluntad es más grande que ti mismo y
donde demuestras que tienes fuerza de
voluntad para salir adelante y con
coraje levantarte y demostrarte a ti
mismo porque créanme no hay nada más
bonito no hay nada más bonito que
regalar sea uno mismo el empezar desde
cero y vivir viendo cómo se vas
construyendo todo hasta llegar a algo
padre y algo chivo en que te has
construido y eso nadie te lo da ni el
dinero te lo da esto pero las tú
cuando estaba propagando esta plática me
preguntaron max todos sueñan años de
modelaje y de excesos te sirvieron
te ayudaron o te jalaron o lo es
negativo
realmente yo no lo sea
pero si sé que fue una experiencia muy
fuerte y que me trajo aquí y me siento
muy honrado y muy feliz de estar
compartiendo un poquito de historia de
mi historia con ustedes quiero agradecer
a dios a mi familia a mis amigos que
nunca me dejaron a pesar que los aleje
todos esos años
y los dejo con una frase que a mí me
encanta y me gusta mucho que es nunca es
tarde para emprender un nuevo rumbo
vivir una historia y construir un nuevo
sueño muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]